[Music]
fallout 4 is finally out in many of us
have spent the past two weeks bounding
around the wastelands blowing feral
ghouls heads off collecting Raiders arms
and searching for cans of green paint
hmm in dozens of ways fallout 4 is an
incredibly familiar game to fans of
Bethesda's open-world or PGs you spend a
lot of time wandering on familiar
landscapes bumping into friends and foes
it's a game about walking into the
unforgiving wilderness without ever
truly knowing what's around the next
corner it's a place full of life
battered people folks who hide behind
walls travel in packs and rally around
shared ideologies all in the search of
one thing safety but in one way in
particular fallout 4 is actually very
different so today on the point I'm
going to talk about the power of our
surroundings and how hanging up light
bulbs and building furniture has forever
changed our relationship with the
waistline
[Music]
for those who don't know fallout 4
includes a base building component which
allows you to set up communities with
housing farms and trade routes it also
acts as a sort of first-person stage
create mode where you can build and move
furniture and hang pictures of cats on
the walls at first it seems entirely
superfluous a tip of the hat to modders
and the minecraft generation something
you can easily ignore a threat your time
in the wasteland a fun site activity to
waste a few minutes with then why is it
that I've spent 10 hours of the game
faffing about with it tinkering with my
community building houses setting up
farms scrapping everything within sight
placing furniture setting up mood
lighting and haphazardly cramming all my
Nuka Cola bottles into this
pre-apocalypse fridge well it could be
that I just love interior design but I
don't think that's the case in fact to
explain why myself and so many other
people of bizarre d found comfort in
scrapping tires and raising picket
fences we have to look at the other
inhabitants of the wasteland I said it
once and I'll say it again fallout 4 is
a game obsessed with death the lives of
those in the wasteland is sat on the
very foundations of death and decay and
the primary goal of those left alive is
staying that way regardless of their
role within the wasteland each person
your character is primarily preoccupied
with one thing staying alive now safety
comes in many forms it can be as simple
as a roof over your head and a plate of
food for some it's holding a gun for
others it's being surrounded by people
you trust and you can see this truth in
the cities 10 ships and clans of the
waistline inhabitants of diamond city
are surrounded by the walls of Fenway
with a supply of somewhat fresh water
and food they're so sure of their safety
that their concerns lie in matters of
free speech rights and
self-actualization the city of good
neighbor a township of social outcasts
who found comfort in banding together
the railroad Brotherhood of Steel a
Minuteman groups that find comfort in
shared ideas even Raiders rarely travel
alone they might be crazy but they're
still band together by a sense of groups
safety and it's in that way that your
character the vault dweller has always
been different to everyone else in the
waistline the vault dweller has forever
been a tourist in somebody else's world
a fish out of water capable of changing
the direction of the wasteland society
without any real stake or claim to it
but with the addition of sanctuary
something has changed well since you say
that maybe you'll come to sanctuary with
us we could use your help getting
settled there there's a moment very
early on in the game where Preston
Garvey tells you he's shepherding his
group of settlers towards sanctuary the
very same town you lived in prior to the
bombs being dropped and the moment
Preston told me that I felt like
somebody had stolen my candy but that's
where I live I wanted to tell him that's
my home this before ever touching the
base building mechanics of the game and
this reaction is the same reason but
there's the have added so many livable
spaces to Skyrim and why modders are so
quick to add homes and fallout games
because in a game like fallout were
desperate for a safe place to call our
own and while you can happily just buy
property in other parts of the wasteland
there's a comfort in creating the space
around you which tickles our reptile
brains like nesting before a child is
born or hanging up old posters when
you've moved into a new house humans
seek comfort in many ways with the
ability to make a safe space in a
terrifying world is something we all
understand at some level and the thing
is this has totally changed how many of
us play fallout after long quest lines
finish I now go home to sanctuary to
collect myself to dump off scraps store
my guns and drop off any magazines
bobbleheads or balls of Nuka Cola life
and along the way I do a little DIY
maybe clean up the house or cater to my
neighbors needs it's changed how I quest
no longer do I carry shed loads of guns
and items like a wandering vagabond my
home base is my new inventory and before
each quest I suit up [__] and food and
set out quests aren't quests anymore
they've become expeditions and home is
always there if I need to flee and it's
this sense of home that's changed where
my allegiance lies when asked to choose
between my neighbors and another group I
side with those I share a power
generator with time may have passed and
bonds strained but in the
settlers of sanctuary I found a new
family and its in this way the fallout 4
is completely different to every other
game in this series no longer are we
simply observers wandering cypher is
playing God with lives that we have
little stakin now we're true
wastelanders inhabitants of the
post-apocalypse who like everyone else
in this death consume land has found
comfort in a group of people a set of
familiar comforting walls and a unifying
idea to survive
[Music]
you